[Musique]
allô monsieur monsieur le maire david
charasse et cyril hanouna sarah bien
alors on a en direct à la télé david
parce qu'on parlait de vous au sujet de
bernadette chirac
vous voulez vous faire un petit bisou en
direct et j'ai eu une roquette d'un et
chroniqueur qui me dit qu'il faudrait
baisser le péage entre antibes et cannes
est ce que c'est possible parce que je
reçois en paix en tant qu'automobiliste
santé longtemps qu'on cible les contrats
de délégation de service cas c'est pas
très sympa et je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai mais s'est cassé le monopole au
quartier de monsieur c'est au détriment
de david quain d'amour bisous bravo
david est bon on va faire ça le match en
direct à la télé s'est vu tomber en
panne
on parle du jour de l'an la caisse et
que sacra sera là tu nous as me sophie
d'abord daphné bürki et poste une bonne
après retue me qu'on meurt ou boire
parce que la marche m'occuper de ça
parce que j'ai trois enfants que je
m'occupe de bessan qu'est ce qui se
passe on est sur 31 décembre il ya plus
patrick sébastien il paraissait sophie
da bank daphné bürki et faustine
bollaert qui vont faire le 31 décembre
de de france 2 qui tu veux tu veux
précieuses les veines déjà pour
commencer l'année au moins
[Applaudissements]
le peso la norme non mais c'est pas
d'axa maître d'art cas ou pas il s'avère
qu'à mais alex et net je voulais des
c'est la meilleure quoi ça va être leur
cas sera sûrement laissé ce succès
l'achète qu'on est là que c'est que du
positif et des valeurs positives on
détourne à tous dans le même sens
c'est la nouvelle année et ça ça va être
un plateau de dingue avec des supers
variété va y avoir de tout spectacle
tous les artistes sont là donc ça va
être super belle amy c'est l'affairé la
préparer j'ai déjà appelé comme ça
franchement je vous le dis alors
franchement tu es lapin telle a été la
meilleure avec 120 avec les merdes que
vous mettez en façe à deux doigts d'y
aller moi-même le jour de l'an sur ces
vies je peux pas satané pour l'argent
rester calmes et vous me direz que vous
mettrez en face qe2 quelque chose en
face de ma singer un moment parce que
les rediff ça suffit allez merci je
t'embrasse ma chérie dealer à la
programmation la série parle allez salut
à l'eau alors oui mais ça va on à
l'antenne nature répond non nous allons
québécois 18h42 je fais des fougasses
dis moi non j'ai à trois cadeaux à
composer alors à quand je t'explique
façon l'anniversaire des cadeaux bon
anniversaire
mais cette jolie bon anniversaire
dix mois alors quoi pas l'antenne mais
tu sais bien tu finis l'antenne à 4
heures du matin bon alors je dispute le
quartier on embrasse le monde tout en
vrac et ou chinois baba alors il y avait
il y avait 3 il y avait trois cadeaux il
ya eu un beau qu'il a ou un bouquet de
fleurs de jean michel maire ou le cadre
ou à cadre avec mono valdes est bon
alors c'est le bouquet ou bien mathieu
delormeau kit offre un cadre dégueulasse
non ou bien bernard montiel qui t'habite
à déjeuner
[Applaudissements]
et
j'ai compris tu choisis le bouquet de
jean-michel voilà jean michel bavoil à
breuil t'embrasse très fort entre brad
may bonne anniversaire
merci merci je t'embrasse attendez
attendez c'est mon fils fola allô allô
oui je suis à l'antenne série qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui nos alors tu
dois me restait lettre trois premiers
avaient abaissé son chip abc sensible
voilà dossier
j'avais je t'aime mon chéri exceptionnel
n'hésite pas à rappeler zidane aux
blagues
j'adore je t'aime mon chéri tu salut mon
cul au téléphone à bourges à la la la
ouais jonathan je suis désolé mais je
sais pas si tôt quand tu l'as vu mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et si je commence à connaître la bombe
démission je tombais l'eau pour jamal
s'il te parle
jonathan merci vous allez franchement il
est désolé c'est pas la faute de julien
voilà c'est une femme tous les jours sur
m 6 à 12 ans john a tort d'accord je
n'attendais très sympa mais on appelle
le grand patron le grand patron du canal
savamment jirane nom alors je me dis moi
tu sais où elle est où elle est où
gérald
comment ça va mon général tu nous
regardes des mon chéri
mais bon on est bons gérald brice viret
que j'embrasse mon chéri qu'un amour ça
le manque d'amour telles bombes
[Applaudissements]